with all the rot that is in this
administration you have to start asking
what are the president's priorities well
biden has decided not to clean house
in the white house like white house
staff he's decided to clean house at the
president's council on sports fitness
and nutrition
and by that i mean force out two trump
appointees still sitting on it because
sports is now politicized the white
house sent letters to both dr mehmed oz
and hershel walker telling them to
resign by 6 pm last night or be fired
they both chose the latter one of them
is here to tell us why herschel walker
george a senate candidate and former nfl
player extraordinaire joins me now
herschel
so that's it
i guess you're officially off the off
the council for just being you
oh well i am and uh you know with so
much going on in this country i cannot
believe
he's gonna think that herschel walker is
going to quit well i think he don't know
herschel walker and he sent me the
letter at 10 o'clock asking me to resign
or they're going to fire me at 6.
so i say i'm not going to quit so i
reckon they're going to fire me but i
haven't got the letter that they fired
me at
well herschel i think they're they're
pegging this to the fact that you and
oz um are running for office
and they say you can't sit on the sports
council while you're doing that and it's
per the hatch act even though you're not
actually in office yet so i'm not sure
if that really makes sense but
your response to that they say it's not
partisan enough well you know
where it's very interesting because i'm
not supposed to use the council while
i'm out campaigning and i've never have
used the counselor while i've been
campaigning and that's what was so
strange is uh they sent me the letter
why they know that i'm out campaigning
where i'm raising money because i'm
going to win the senate seat and i think
that's what they thought they can do is
throw me off track but this letter is
not going to do it
the way they're going to have to throw
me off track is they're going to have to
get out and they're going to have to
show that these policies that they're
making right now is going to be great
for georgia and great for america
well hershel speaking of the race
i was wondering what the latest poll
said
and right now
you're leading raphael warnock by four
points um given how you know high
inflation is energy prices in the state
everywhere hitting georgians especially
hard
um do you expect that
to increase or do you expect this to say
stay pretty close
well i expected the increase and the
reason i say that is it seemed that
they're not going to try to make
anything better right now they're
doubling down and they're going back and
blaming everyone else except blaming
themselves right now we can be energy
independent they don't even want to do
that we can start doing things for
ourselves they don't even want to do
that they continue to hurt georgia they
continue to hurt the american people so
they seem to be doubling down
trying to make this country terrible
putting us second well america is not
second and i'm not going to settle for
that that's the reason i'm running
that's the reason i got in the raise i'm
not going to settle for second place
this is the greatest country in the
world
and herschel what's your message to
african-american voters
in georgia
many of whom have have suffered failing
schools uh increased crime rates and
uh in city areas especially what's your
message and what can republicans do to
reach out
well i think what republicans can do to
reach out is first of all get better
messages in a sense and let them know
that you know what what they uh what the
republicans stands for is what african
americans believe in they believe in
education they believe in a school
choice they believe in uh public safety
they believe in all the things that uh
all the democrats are telling that they
don't and i think they're seeing it now
you look at this economy right now and i
think they're starting to see that all
the messages that they thought that they
were that we were we're not and uh right
now they believe in this country you
know i'm sorry i'm sad to say that
herschel walker got an id
they i can get my own id i'm smart
enough to have an id and you know what
it's so strange is i also know that i
can vote you know we can get out and we
can vote we don't need people telling us
that we can't vote that we're not
suppressed and i can find america's
dream here all right in the united
states of america
all right hershel great to see you
tonight sorry about the council on
physical fitness now while biden
embarrassed us in europe kamala didn't
have to travel far to do so the last
fight explains hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else